auteur des travaux on va dire il est 50%
sur le champ 50%
en gros sur les bases 10 avec la reprise
d'activité sur les chantiers le besoin
en main d'oeuvre se fait ressentir les
entreprises se focalisent leurs
recrutements notamment sur les apprentis
c'est le cas de ce grand groupe
une quinzaine de postes en apprentissage
est proposée tous deux chantiers ont été
arrêtés du coup beaucoup de retard sur
certains lots chantier donc on a besoin
de main d'oeuvre et nous chez vinci on a
une forte politique jeunes aussi donc
tous les ans contexte particulier ou pas
on a besoin on recrute d'apprentis pour
cette pme spécialisée dans les
canalisations l'assainissement et l'eau
potable échantillons été reportée
pendant le confinement des recrutements
sont nécessaires pour sa reprise
d'activité on a un manque de main
d'oeuvre aujourd'hui et pour le futur
proche avec des chefs de chantier ou une
manoeuvre vieillissante donc il faut
former aujourd'hui pour garder une
dynamique il conserver à voir des jeunes
pour demain l'impact des faits kévin
c'est que ça a retardé
nos chantiers deux mois mais aujourd'hui
ce soit sur le volume il n'y a pas eu de
baisse ni d'augmentation sont à 100 c ap
bts et bac professionnel toutes les
filières du centre de formation des
métiers du btp à trappes sont en
apprentissage malgré la crise sanitaire
la structure a organisé cette journée
objectif faciliter les rencontres entre
les entreprises et les jeunes dans le
domaine des travaux publics la demande
est forte
on a des demandes des grands groupes des
multinationales dont des agents sont
implantés dans les yvelines
et on a aussi une demande importante
des entreprises
type pme ou des entreprises artisanales
on a beaucoup craint il ya quelques mois
que les
que les demandes soient soit très limité
les grâces aussi peut-être aux aides à
l'apprentissage et puis à la confiance
que les entreprises accordent aux jeunes
la demande reste forte donc on est on
est confiant dans la recherche d'une
entreprise pour une formation en
apprentissage parfois un véritable
parcours du combattant
un sentiment renforcé par le contexte
actuel même sens le vide
c'est toujours compliqué de trouver une
entreprise en alternance c'est assez
long même si on s'y prend à cette eau on
a toujours des réponses assez lente par
rapport aussi à ce qui s'est passé au
couvent in situ c'est plus difficile
d'avoir des entretiens cetc les
entretiens qu'ont fait par audiovisuel
et parfois ça n'aboutit pas vraiment
faux dans la période du code vide on n'a
pas pu se déplacer n'a pas pu postuler
et ont ensuite eu du mal à les joindre
près de deux cent cinq jeunes sont
formés chaque année en apprentissage au
centre de formation des métiers du btp à
trappes